president-elect joe biden is calling
president trump's refusal to concede an
act of quote incredible irresponsibility
now bipartisan members of former
administrations are pushing
for a peaceful transfer of power
madeleine albright served as bill
clinton's secretary of state and oversaw
the state department's handoff
to the bush administration in 2001
michael chertoff meanwhile served as
president bush's homeland security
secretary
staying in his post until president
obama's inauguration day to ensure a
smooth transition
and the two former secretaries join us
now good morning to you both
secretary chertoff i want to start with
you because you were there
in 2001 after that delayed transition in
the year 2000
it's been pointed out on this broadcast
and others that that may have had an
impact
uh in the administration's response to 9
11. you were there
could you tell us how the transition
affected the government's actions on
that terrible day
well as the commission the 911
commission made
clear because of the delay in transition
which was due to the fact that there was
a dispute about the florida votes there
was
a delay in getting people cleared
nominated
and in taking on positions confirmed
positions at the critical agencies
so i was there and a few other people
were there but we had some vacancies
that were not filled
and that simply put more of a burden on
the people who remained
in office it meant that we were a little
slower to respond
and one of the takeaways from this was
in a world of terrorism
you cannot afford to have a gap between
two administrations
we are still living in that world of
terrorism secretary chertoff so as we
stand today are you worried that there
could be a repeat and we could be
flat-footed again
candidly i'm more worried now than i was
about the situation in 2001 for the
following reasons
first of all there appears to be a
deliberate effort to slow up the
transition
and not to begin the process of clearing
people or
giving presidential briefings
additionally
donald trump is now firing many of the
senior experienced
security officials in his own government
which means that we will be lowering our
defenses
at precisely the moment that our
adversaries
whether they be nation states or
terrorists
recognized that there's a vulnerability
so this is really playing recklessly
with the safety and security of the
american people
secretary albright i want to turn to you
now we heard health and human services
secretary azar say earlier this morning
that basically everything is public and
the the incoming biden administration
doesn't need any extra help what's your
reaction to that comment
well frankly i was appalled because i
think that
it is irresponsible and the biden people
are fully cognizant of the dangers
that have to do with covet and how it
has been mishandled
and the act that it has to be something
that is done for the health and the
lives of american people
and i find it stunning that we can be
constantly being told
that everything is normal and this is
the most selfish
irresponsible response to what is going
on domestically and
uh internationally and i so agree with
secretary chertoff on this
that it is something that should make us
very nervous
and very suspicious of everything that
is going on because we are being lied to
but you know secretary albright a recent
poll of republican shows that more than
half of them
think that this election was rigged
what's your reaction to that well i have
to say i'm stunned
because i believe in bipartisanship and
i believe in the truth
and i don't believe that it is
responsible of them
in many ways not to assess what is going
on
and i i find this a tragic time
in many ways having been through a
number of transitions myself
the importance of them they are a period
where the crown jewels are transferred
where people are talking to each other
about what happens next
and there really is a responsibility in
terms of understanding what
is good for the american people and not
the selfishness
and kind of blindness i i find it very
hard to even find the right nouns
to describe what is going on you know
guys secretary
cherdoff if you could take this one you
know there have been many times in this
administration where the sentences
started
this has never happened before this is
unprecedented
i'm wondering what are you and your
republican homies saying about this when
you look at this
and you see the number of people that
are not speaking up what is your
reaction to that and what is your
conversation with each other
about how we move forward well candidly
i'm not having that much conversation
with republicans
i am very disappointed and appalled that
the number of republicans
who are standing by either silently or
actually trying to enable
these absolutely ridiculous conspiracy
theories
whenever the trump campaign has gone to
court they have not been able to produce
any evidence of significant fraud
in fact now a lot of the lawyers for the
campaign are bailing out
because they realize that if they go in
and present a case with no evidence
they run the risks of getting sanctioned
so now we have the specter of rudy
giuliani
with paint running down his face that
was hair dye that was hair dye second
well
it looked like paint hair paint look
looking yeah you know basically coming
up with outlandish theories
and propagating them in public fora
so this is a very dangerous time for the
country even after the transition
we're going to have a significant number
of people who are accepting conspiracy
theories
of the most outlandish sort we need to
figure out
how to repair our societal cohesiveness
um or we're going to be in very very
serious trouble going forward
secretary albright in about 30 seconds
that we have left could you talk about
step
one at least in repairing that gap in
trust uh
in our elections well i think that we're
all going to have to talk to each other
try to figure out what is the motivating
factor
and decide that we need to unify the
country
uh this is a time where unity is needed
and understanding
and i think those of us that have a
sense of what america
is about need to begin talking to the
others it is serious
this is very bad we can't go on like
this we need to understand what it is
kander from both you we appreciate it
secretaries thank you very much we'll be
right back